[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I'm praying what I'm hearing isn't true
honestly my first reaction was just like
dude like why why I don't know him I
don't know him like that
okay so I think we're at a time where
everyone's really waking up to the way
that we abuse our power devastated and
enraged baby Cummings and speaking out
about the allegations against Chris
Delia if what she's saying is true I
don't think you can come back from that
it's over bro that's a bad look but with
that case mysteriously being dropped
Chris would have you believe that he's a
family man now working diligently to get
through his sex addiction
um I stand by the fact that all my
relationships have been consensual and
legal two weeks ago the crystallia
problem was uploaded to YouTube and our
long documentary summarizing the
allegations made against Chris in the
summer of 2020 related to the potential
grooming of young women the documentary
then goes on to claim that since his
initial cancellation chrysalia has now
put a stop to his old ways despite what
he said in his apology video now
although the chrysalia problem presents
all their evidence in a very convincing
way it's still technically all hearsay
no legal accident has been taken yet and
given that that's the case today's video
is solely focused on comedians reactions
to the crystalia problem I know that
it's been a really long time since
you've heard from me and when the news
broke
I put out a statement that said
everything I've done has been legal and
consensual and that's true
and I wanted that statement to speak for
itself so the crystalia problem was
upload to Youtube on December 20th 2022
and currently stands over half a million
views some of the new claims against
Chris highlight in this video are that
he wants to create a real-life sex cult
and has continued to be unfaithful in
his marriage despite rebranding as a
family man New Year's resolution for
crystallia what do we think
I say throw your phone in the ocean
no don't let them break you Chris don't
let them break
up change your facial hair and throw
your phone in the ocean
in 2023 Crystal yeah needs to stop
worrying about what everyone thinks and
just go for it
this is your year man just [ __ ] move
forward
at the New Year same you
he's like you know what this year more
young [ __ ] yeah
here's an idea Chris check out the
political side of tick tock
maybe learn some life hacks his New
Year's resolution needs to be getting
more hot young [ __ ] yeah dude [ __ ]
triple down there is something cool well
not cool let me rephrase
let me rephrase there is something
impressive about his steadfastness you
know what I mean when somebody calls you
out and you go yeah I'm I'm good like
he's still you know forging ahead
there's something about forging yeah he
didn't even Flinch he was like you know
what dude whatever an hour-long
compelling documentary I don't care yeah
oh yeah you have like a sex cult I love
the idea of him giving like a
motivational speech to the girls he's
like listen we're down we're not out
I know many of you are looking at these
windows thinking you're gonna get out
tonight and get on a bus and go live
your life but I'm telling you right now
that is not gonna happen dude I would
say with Josh Adam Meyers that he has so
many like plates spinning at the same
time with all those girls that it's like
he has to [ __ ] up and he's like so you
excited to get your new crystallia
initials tattoo and she's like I got my
tattoo three weeks ago he goes oh [ __ ]
is this Jennifer all right okay oh yeah
so uh is it healing up good or what I
gotta make a call I have a question yeah
why'd you include the fact that you were
saying that to Josh Adam Meyers oh you'd
have just said it to us and not included
Josh Adam Meyers I was involved in this
so I like to give a little bibliography
what did he say he's like
that's funny hey that's great
it was just a sex Cult of underage girls
in Hollywood name was christalia life
rips
Nikki Glaser is another big name in
comedy who said that she watched the
first half of the documentary before
sharing her thoughts on an episode of
the Nikki Glazer podcast that aired last
week it's really a shame that he is this
person it's a shame that someone that
had that does have that town this much
talent and that much likability is that
much of a [ __ ] weirdo and like can't
can't help himself how embarrassing
did you feel that way Anya like there's
no coming back from this kind of thing
of like oh boy he asked them what was
the one there was one line that I go
nope I'll no matter what is distinct of
this I'll never forget this part I
forget it now but it was just the daddy
part where she's like I already have a
daddy and he's like I'm your daddy
that kind of turns me on but listen this
is my problem not yours no no it was um
him trying to get them all to live
together oh yeah what
he tried to get these girls he wanted a
harem he wanted a house that he could go
to and they one would [ __ ] him one would
suck him one would feed him one would
massage him one would like bathe clean
him I mean this is just the girls what
they were saying this wasn't like
reading his text so maybe they were
paraphrasing but he wanted he wanted to
like
you know have these girls human
centipeding him from every angle Annie
Letterman was the first comedian that I
saw publicly acknowledge the documentary
she posted a picture on her Instagram a
screenshot of the video the day after it
was uploaded with the caption this new
season of Mexico rips when I saw that
she posted this on IG I was kind of
shocked because they're kind of like
co-workers in a way I also went to one
of Annie Letterman's shows last year in
Tampa and she made some sort of crowd
work joke about how the age of consent
in Florida lines up with Chris Leah's
age of consent something like that and I
remember being shocked in that moment
being like damn like you're really going
after another comedian in public like
how does that work is it gonna be
awkward when you guys are back in La
kind of on the same shows and gigs and
stuff but then I remembered though that
Annie Letterman's home Club is The
Comedy Store which Chris Alia is still
not welcome back from his initial
cancellation so they're probably good at
this point you're probably wondering
well what did Chris say about all this
surely he's made some sort of video
defending himself or apologizing again
right well not really in his latest
episode of congratulations his solo
podcast Chris Leah mentioned that he's
back in rehab for his sex addiction
however he also said that all these
episodes are pre-recorded a bit so
there's no way to know if this is in
response to the documentary or if this
is just a coincidence that he brought
that up in the middle of all this
actually I went to [ __ ] nobody knows
about this but I went to rehab
um and I I don't know if I was gonna
tell people this or not but I did I go I
went to rehab I was there for over a
month I went back in November and um we
pre-record a lot of the [ __ ]
um and
just should have done it this whole time
honestly like should have done it years
ago didn't
because I had excuses in my head about
covet and [ __ ] but uh and all that and
uh but yeah the uh
I did it because I I had to you know for
for uh my addiction and all that [ __ ]
and I I need to be present and but my
God it was a trauma-based thing I went
in November uh through December and
it was just like
I don't know what to say about it man
food was trash
the food was [ __ ] trash get it
together at the end of the day
everyone's gonna form their own opinion
on crystalia anyway like most things in
life the truth probably lies somewhere
more in the middle of complete guilt and
total innocence I mean if everything
said in this documentary is true he'd be
in jail right now but also usually wear
their smoke there's fire and I guess
that's the main takeaway from the
chrysalia problem in lighter news Bill
Cosby announced that he's playing to
tour this spring
seriously I have no idea how or why this
is happening but apparently Bill Cosby
announced he has plans to tour in the
spring of 2023 and said quote when I
come out of this I feel I'll be able to
perform and be the Bill Cosby that my
audience knows me to be
there's really nothing funny to add on
to this because just the fact that this
is real and not a South Park sketch is
funny enough for me I mean like he how
is this gonna happen how is any venue
gonna be on board with this the tickets
would probably sell because people would
just want to be like is this real like I
I guess I would go to that I'd report it
on the comedy news but I mean talk about
heckling the fact that this guy thinks
he's going to be able to actually
perform comedy anywhere and people are
going to want to listen for comedy's
sake is hysterical to me
it's the biggest serial rapist in
recorded human history announced a
spring Comedy Tour
how is that not funny guest spots from
last week your mom's house did not have
a guest two bears one cave was Burton
Tom and Bert whiskey Ginger had a
Margaret Cho kill Tony tonight is David
and Lona Lucas flagrant did not have a
guest imagine secret podcast had on
Bobby Kelly it was the worst I remember
they had to do jumping jacks [ __ ] I I
actually said to the guy I go dude
what do you think of what do you think I
got I don't have any I think I'm really
stuffing heroin in my ass to make money
and and I'm gonna be out in three months
I'm not I'm not going to be here it's
not a life sentence
you have to do ass naked jumping jacks
and you have to squat
naked [ __ ] humiliated that's terrible
yeah terrible terrible and that was the
first time that was the first time yeah
that was the first time you didn't learn
your lesson
no it's the thing about drugs and
alcohol
funny thing about about doing drugs and
alcohol yeah you know it's a hard time
it took me three more years the last
time I got arrested was for a gumball
machine
but what'd you do I stole a number
machine you took the whole thing took
two of them nice do you want the coins
or the gum yeah both guys we're never
gonna need to buy bubble gum again
son of a [ __ ] they got me
this past weekend with the Yvonne head
on James Blake The Joe Rogan Experience
had on Dave Portnoy a very overdue
episode in my opinion we might be drunk
to not have a guest the Honeydew had on
Chappelle Lacy tigerbelly posted their
best moments of 2022. Joe Rogan was the
guest on the Tim Dylan show this week
big episode and Stavros was on bad
friends as far as new stamp specials go
ones are coming out soon I know we've
talked about the last three episodes but
tomorrow January 10th Andrew Santino
cheeseburger comes out on Netflix it's a
big deal I think it's gonna be really
good we're gonna do a video with fans
reactions to the special but another
angle on this because usually when
someone puts out a Netflix special they
do the podcast rounds to promote it if
we get Andrew Santino and all the major
podcasts that'd be pretty sweet so we'll
maybe try not to laugh Andrew Santino's
coming up too also we posted a try not
to laugh and soda compilation the other
day I feel like it's not getting as many
views as it deserves soder's so funny
let's go pump that one up if you're
watching this one next video check out
try not to laugh and Soder other
specials though we have ornie Adams
takes a third a full hour on YouTube and
Netflix put out their best of 2022
specials that has some Christmas Stefano
in it has some Bill Burr it has a lot of
good stuff Sam Morrell so go check that
one out on Netflix and if you want a top
five countdown of specials from last
year we also have a video on our Channel
counting those ones down for you but
that does it for this episode of the
joke World comedy update as always thank
you so much for watching this video and
we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news in the meantime
make sure you like And subscribe and
comment all that kind of stuff I'll stop
bugging you about it but yeah just do it
if you feel like supporting the channel
follow us on Instagram GMS if you want
any free joke World stickers
um yeah we'll see you next Monday sorry
for this this is like a very serious
episode full of like crystalline and
Bill Cosby stories so uh next one will
be more of a positive vibe I hope okay
goodbye
[Music]